this is a graph of deaths man-made
deaths from or starting at beginning of
the 20th century
and your notice first world war takes us
up to about six million deaths in one
year of 1918 I suppose the second world
there there's the Spanish Civil War that
beep in the middle actually the smaller
one the smaller one right there and then
the Second World War the most
destructive war in human history fifteen
million deaths in 1943 partly from the
Holocaust partly from the the actual
battles but then something very curious
happens in 1945
yes man-made deaths from war drop to a
low of around two million and pretty
much stay there for the rest of the 20th
century and up to today now there are
various speculations about why major war
seems to have been abandoned at least I
think the only one that's really
credible is the nuclear weapons made the
kinds of wars that that that blighted
the twentieth century no longer possible
to fight the dream of the 30s was that
aerial bombardment would be a sufficient
deterrent to stop the war but it wasn't
destructive enough the bombs that were
dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
implied a level of destruction that
seems to have convinced even as
belligerent a state as the United States
or the Soviet Union or any of the other
religions of the 20th century that they
would their own nation would be
destroyed if we or someone else tried to
destroy an enemy their arguments on both
sides and I there's no way to prove it
one way or the other but as history as
time continues if world scale war truly
has been ended I think it will be
because we finally discovered an
explosive that basically is infinite in
potential scale we're left then today
all these years after this little war
that was so hopeful and so sadly Scotch
those hopes we're left in with the world
where on the one hand we're living a
much more peaceful world a couple
million deaths a year is nothing to be
proud of to be sure but it's four
million fewer than died from smoking
so we found a we found an inoculation if
you will but the other side of that of
course is that if the bombs go off then
we will have destruction on a scale far
beyond anything that this graph depicts
even it turns out a small regional
nuclear war say between India and
Pakistan would produce sufficient smoke
and soot from burning cities to cause of
tooth drop in average annual
temperatures worldwide of about two to
three degrees which is enough to
reproduce the summer without a year
without a summer of 1816 when the
volcano Tambora caused the Sun to be
darkened enough to cause hard freezes in
New England in July so we live in a very
different and ironically more peaceful
but more precarious age than these
people did and I think perhaps the last
thing I would say is it's probably a lot
harder to be heroic
[Music]